bonjour dépêchez vous julie vient
justement de réunir les enfants du
jardin pour leur raconter une histoire
ils sont là bas
il était une fois il ya fort longtemps
un petit chaperon orange qui allait voir
son grand père
il lui fallait pour arriver jusqu'à sa
maison traverser une grande forêt très
sombre et très profonde il avait emporté
dans son panier un grand pont de
gloubiboulga
avec casimir qu'est ce qui t'arrive que
tout essoufflé tu as fait la course
quels sont tes adversaires je donnais
pas je cours tout seul mais je suis
surveillé et contrôlé entre années qu'on
ne mettrait dirigé par massoud hushovd
il fait tout ça à la fois ah oui enfin
c'est de voir ce qu'il prétend mais dis
moi pourquoi est en train de tuer avec
autant de sérieux a baissé pour
améliorer ma forme ta forme mais tu m'as
que tu es fatigué non non pas du tout
non il s'agit de cette forme là ah bon
tu veux maigrir oui c'est ça j'aimerais
que ma forme soit un peu plus ça comme
ça c'est très bien mais il faudra pas
que tu exagères on j'aimerais beaucoup
être un peu plus belle parce que j'en ai
assez d'entendre monsieur du snob me
traiter de gros barney
mais quel est ton programme
d'entraînement ça vous intéresse
vraiment bien sûr mais moi je parierais
que tu as déjà fait le tour de nicolas
non non non c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça c'est en cross c'est
très difficile mais très efficace enfin
c'est du moins ce que prétend monsieur
du scope et comment ça se passe aux
libyens j'ai d'abord fait la première
épreuve alors la première époque j'ai
d'abord couru pendant 50 m à plat dans
le sable ça ce n'est pas trop fatiguant
oui maintenant ce n'est pas tout ensuite
je courais toujours et j'ai grimpé une
bulle en cours en gérant descendu la
rumeur
oulala c'est déjà plus ce n'est pas tout
j'ai encore couru 81 mettre à plat dans
le sable qu'ils rencontrent je rentre
descendu la bulle et je traversais toute
la plage les mollets dans l'eau avec ça
c'est excellent casimir mais dis moi que
faisait monsieur distincts pour
l'instant on pense travail était de la
dune et il me surveillait oui il
chronométrait chaque fois que je
ralentissais il me traitait de gros
balourd c'est vraiment du bon allez il
faut que je me prépare pour la deuxième
est proche la deuxième épreuve oui
oui mais je reviendrai à tout voir tout
à l'heure ah bon bah moi je continue mon
histoire pour lui raconter une histoire
qu'est ce que c'est oui celle du petit
chaperon orange et de sandouville
bulgaro c'est l'histoire que je préfère
j'aimerais bien rester casimir tu viens
pas la ville il faut vraiment que j'y
aille si je veux maigrir
messieurs du jeune homme fait attention
à lui à ne le fatigue et pas trop vous
inquiétez pas
d'imagés sur place
donc le petit chaperon - orange
trottinait dans la forêt avec son gros
pot de gloubiboulga au bras c'était un
délicieux gloubiboulga le chocolat râpé
était parfait la confiture de fraises
était délicieuse la moutarde était de
dijon les balades était mûr à point
quant aux saucisses de toulouse elle été
cru mais hors de la partie de l'histoire
que je préfère
[Musique]
c'était un excellent gloubiboulga le
petit chaperon orange était sûr que son
grand père aimerait beaucoup ça et ne
voulait surtout pas le donner aux chefs
des tyrannosaures juil tu en es toujours
gloubiboulga enfin surtout au petit
chaperon orange
oh la la cette fois ça va être difficile
sont pas sûrs de réussir mais de quoi
s'agit-il voilà il s'agit d'un d'un
triple saut oui il faut tomber courir à
tomber sur le pied droit le pied gauche
et puis les deux pieds je vais vous
montrer regarder ça se passe comme ça on
prend son élan
c'est ça qu'on a l'air tout à l'heure
donc nous reprenons notre histoire
jamais rien faire jusqu'au bout
eh bien je continue bon ben moi je sais
plus où j'en suis vous savez vous les
enfants où on en est nos petits
champions orange 120 avec son petit pot
de gouville d'or voilà alors le petit
chapeau orange trottinant dans la forêt
rencontre qui devenaient les enfants
mais non il rencontre son grand-père
il s'approche de lui il lui tend la main
et il la trouve très velud casimir
qu'est ce qui t'arrive tu es tombé à
l'eau mais non pas du tout je viens de
prendre mon bain dalle bon c'est
toujours ta cure d'amaigrissement petit
sens bien je suis très content j'ai
maigri d'au moins quelques centaines de
grammes
ce qui est très bien c'est que monsieur
du jeune homme a promis de s'occuper de
moi tous les jours c'est très bien
casimir il faut persévérer mais dis moi
tu ferais bien d'aller de sécher parce
que tu vas attraper froid bon j'y vais
la raison
donc
il lui tend la main il la trouve très
velud il lève la tête
et il trouve que ses oreilles sont très
longues alors le grand père lui demande
qu'as-tu dans ton grand pau
j'ai du gloubiboulga
répond le petit chaperon orange du
gloubiboulga c'est un plat délicieux
demande le grand-père faut certainement
grand père répond le petit chaperon
rouge
et
casimir
qu'est ce que tu fais tu viens pas
écouté la fin de l'histoire non non je
ne peux pas il faut que je mange un peu
j'ai besoin de reprendre des forces à aa
et qu'est ce que tu manges ou un tout
petit peu de gloubiboulga
un peu de bluebeam boulga mais dis moi
un gloubi boulga chéreau ça tu n'as pas
honte le jour où tu commences une cure
d'amaigrissement
tu manges plus que d'habitude pendant ça
c'est pas faux julie comment ça de ma
faute mais oui écoutent chaque fois que
je passais près du bord tu parlais de
gloubiboulga je n'ai pas pu résister
mois que
j'attends casimir qui va venir
travailler ces exercices de danse il est
en retard comme d'habitude
casimir adorent danser mais ça l'ennuie
de travail et d'un certain côté je le
comprends ça n'est pas toujours très
drôle seulement pour être un grand
danseur il faut travailler énormément
la vie est belle et je suis en pleine
forme
je crois que le voilà qu
casimir
je sais que tu te caches
et que tu es là
de toute façon ça ne servira à rien
plus tu viendras tard plus ta leçon
commence rattache aux
eaux je n'ai pas envie de travailler je
ne me sens pas bien du tout oui tu veux
le faire croire que tu es malade oui je
suis malade oui j'ai mal à la tête pion
pied ouais j'ai mal aux mains aussi oui
j'ai mal au ventre au coeur donc c'est
le cas
aux yeux et j'ai même malouda aux
monteurs qui n'a pas de dents ah oui
c'est vrai j'avais oublié et inventer
des excuses et au travail mais bon
puisqu'il faut y aller
alors comme d'habitude première position
1 2 grand plié 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 allée
bien tire un deux trois quatre
procédures de sint-gillis bon je vais
faire les mouvements avec toi
de tout ça c'est beaucoup plus facile
halléguen
2 à oui mais étant il faut que j'aille
me changer de tenue alors pendant que je
m'en vais tu continues à travailler tes
muscles pour qu'ils refroidissent
parvient tout de suite dépêche-toi
bon alors 1 2 3
3 2
des
bas qu'est ce que c'est c'est moi
j'étais bien
vous m'avez fait tellement peur que j'ai
failli tomber ça alors je suis déçu un
casimir j'allais justement félicité me
féliciter on sûr c'est la première fois
que je te vois tu envolé avec grâce
oui bien ces malades vous verrez quand
je saurai le plus grand danseur du monde
boury rémois à j'entends que tu veux
devenir le plus grand danseur du monde
ouah
et pour cela je m'entraîne tous les
jours quand on sait que vous mon cher et
1000 ma part je n'ai jamais rien entendu
d'aussi koubbi remarquez je ne voudrais
pas accabler ce pont au casimir mais
il faut bien reconnaître que tous ces
exercices de danse sont déraisonnables
et les raisonnables dit déraisonnable
c'est bien ou c'est pas bien radiés
et bien déraisonnable c'est quelqu'un
qui n'a pas toute sa raison oui à toi de
juger si c'est bien ou pas bien mais
alors c'est pas bien en tout cas casimir
tous ces exercices sont absolument
inutile car la danse comme tous les
autres arts est un don un don qui est
donnée comme son nom l'indiqué aux
personnes de qualité ou pour ceux qui
auront là une opinion intéressante
dit
vous en connaissez vous des gens qui ont
le don de la dent ouais moi bien sûr eh
bien vous verrez je suis persuadée
d'être meilleurs danseurs que vous avec
mes exercices plutôt que voir pour vos
dons et moi je suis tout à fait que son
avis merci à ma très chère amie que de
joie de vous voir mais ne me dites pas
que vous n'êtes point de mon avis une
danseuse aussi doué que vous même
monsieur du snop moi je m'entraîne tous
les jours comme tous les danseurs la
danse est un art très difficile suffit
pas d'être doué pour réussir il faut
travailler sans cesse oui alors bien je
ne cite pas tenez absolument à défendre
votre élève je lis tu sais je te donne
entièrement raison
leur fasse ça vaut la peine de
travailler si on a des chances de
devenir un grand dans certains esprits
dans le cas de tout casser milliard et
veut croire magazine ne pense pas mal du
tout il a un grand sens du rythme
deuxièmement c'est un exercice excellent
plat dans ce même canton n'est pas un
grand danseur et puis vous 3 au lieu de
vous moquer de casimir vous pourriez
peut-être en faire autant françois tu ne
serais pas si essoufflé après regardons
les deux balles
[Rires]
vous seriez peut-être un peu plus malte
est moins fatigué à la fin de la journée
quant à vous s'ils disent non je ne suis
quand même pas trop gros ou trop maigre
regardez où l'iphone muscles tous les
trois ça vous ferait le plus grand bien
croyez-moi de danser comme casimir
tout le monde à la barre un deux roues
jambes en l'air 1 deux facteurs rentrer
le ventre suivez on repose représ
paration à 2 monsieur du snav ne vous
tortille n'est pas comme un haka ronnie
on recommence cette fois petit battement
sur le coup de pied 1 2 à 2 ensemble
s'il vous plaît première position
flexion avant étirez vous tous monsieur
du snop vous êtes très tôt mais tout
bien casimir à 2 recommençons les pieds
ouverts facteurs les genoux tendu à 2